tesla owner blows up car after twenty
two thousand dollar repair quote can you
imagine blowing up a car
after a twenty two thousand dollar
uh uh uh repair code this is a daily
wire story tesla owner in finland chose
to blow up the car after receiving a
quote of 22 600 to fix it when i bought
that tesla the first 923 mile 32 miles
were nice then error code hit the owner
said the video claimed he was
approximately 66 pounds of dynamite in
the epic explosion of his 2013 tesla
model s the detonation was filmed in
corey reportedly jalla finland the owner
was told the only way to repair the
vehicle was to replace the entire
battery pack the car originally was sold
for only
57 400 400 this is the video by the way
if you want to make it bigger make the
video a little bit bigger so we can all
see it and then let's see what it looks
like when he blows this thing up oh look
at that they're all strong dilly boy
watch this oh boy
this is serious
it's a bit of a light show going on
okay wait for it
holy moly yeah he was not kidding oh boy
holy moly there's parts heading around
so now the question becomes did he make
thirty thousand dollars on marketing
dollars from that video right there
that's the question he did that is a
quarry that's a rock quarry so he found
a place
to safely
detonate all right the late tesla what
do you think about that i think kai is
very bored yeah this is in finland but
the
look what's the most you've ever paid
for uh
for repairs maintenance couple grand nah
not 22 000 that's what i'm saying what
the 20 you get an invoice or a all right
a service service uh invoice for 23 000
the battery pair whatever the hell it is
battery pack how much is an average
battery when you buy a regular car
what's a battery hundred bucks 200 bucks
no this is the battery pack so this is
the entire undercarriage of the car
that's like the engine essentially it is
it is the engine exactly how much is an
engine for a regular car
like a four grand three hundred four
thousand dollars max right is that fair
to say two to four thousand dollars
you know what i drive i drive an amg and
10 years old and i love it but i looked
this up
you know a full replacement a full
rebuild from people that do this
properly 12.5 to to fix the amg engine
to give me the core of the engine tom
that's an 80 000 car that's what i'm
pointing and so that's only 12 and this
is 22. so 40 of the price of the car is
the battery so i i want to know how
common this is yeah meaning
i would be blowing i don't know what
kind of psychopath is that much part of
this story for me it's like first of all
you're gonna blow if this guy blew up
the car i guarantee he's got money
because even if it's twenty two thousand
dollars to repair you paid fifty seven
thousand dollars you can probably sell
the car to somebody for thirty thousand
dollars so there's more story to it it's
gotta be a guy that's a business guy
it's gotta be a guy that's like can you
just screw the market's going to talk
about it let me just blow this thing up
can you just buy dynamite in finland
like can you just buy yeah that's
actually a very good question
you guys just walked into a bass pro
shop and bought 30 pounds of uh like
like
give me all your dynamite yeah like it
was me like it was wiley coyote i was
like
i need uh how do you stick some dynamite
i got a link here with his bio he is a
software programmer
[Laughter]
honey what did you do today uh
sweetie i got like so baked and i did
something really dumb
where's the car vellum he's talking
about baking like a nice cupcake sorry
sorry so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you